that was like I want to be the biggest
movie star in the world to member you
are stuck in line to perfection and that
creates procrastination and so you
always want to tinker and plan and mess
around with it instead of actually doing
the real artist is someone that's damn
near obsessed with it like a painter
should be painting eight hours a day
[Music]
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation eight seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message be obsessed over
to you Will Smith also if you want to
know what Will Smith and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for series where every
day for the next 254 days I will send
you a morning video for free to help you
build your confidence the link to join
is in the description below
I was excited about taking a shot the
fact that it was so strange you know as
an artist it was it was a fun to get out
on that on that limb and hoping it
doesn't break under your feet he told
the famouser bye you kind of backed into
acting Fresh Prince of bel-air yeah and
the next thing you know you start making
these movies and I forget that bad boys
actually came before Independence Day
right yeah yeah tennis day just was like
one of the biggest of all time like what
was that transition like for you yeah
you know actor and like the biggest
actor in the game no it was um that was
like the first real goal like that in
terms of setting goals I was like I want
to be the biggest movie star in the
world right and every up until that
point everything was like it was fun and
it was happening and we were creating in
Jeff's mom's basement and it was
successful but that was like when I
moved into acting that was the first
time I started applying skill to my my
talents right and you know I always look
I look at skill and talent separately
like Pete you're born with talent
you know it's like there's certain
things that you just do naturally
you were gifted with a talent and you
have it but skill is acquired through
discipline and you know I've never seen
myself as particularly talented where I
excel is I'm willing to die in the
process of acquiring skill like is you
know when I put my obsessive mind or
sign I'm just yeah exactly yes you know
not working I said yes is that
ridiculous is sickening work sickening
work ethic exactly it's like you know so
for me to be a movie star was the first
thing that I ever really wanted like
that and set my he was like all of them
I was like I was like you know cuz I
went out when I looked I always felt
like there weren't a lot of people I saw
do things that I felt like I couldn't do
right when I when I look at people and I
see things I don't I don't feel like I
can't whether or not I will is something
different but I don't ever feel like I
can the difference between greatness and
mediocrity is obsession
you are not obsessed enough about
reaching your destination about
accomplishing your goals and so you
haven't the life that you want the
business you want to build you are not
there because it does not reflect in
your habits
you are not obsessed enough about it I
look at Will Smith I love this guy I
consume his info always hope to do a
video on him but Will Smith is not that
special from a talent perspective the
only difference between you and Will
Smith is that he became obsessed
obsessed about accomplishing his goals
you could accomplish everything that
Will Smith did if you had the same level
of obsession that he has the difference
between Will Smith and you is that Will
Smith is obsessed and you are stuck in
procrastination mode so how do you get
out of it and start becoming obsessed
I'm gonna give you three strategies
number one is applied the 595 rule the
595 rule is you spend five percent of
your time thinking and 95 percent of
your time doing five percent of your
time thinking strategizing planning
thinking and creation mode adjusting
your schedule watching videos like this
is is thinking mode five percent of
time and 95% of your time actually out
doing this is the problem this is where
so many entrepreneurs fall down because
we love thinking because thinking is
amazing because thinking about the
better world we can make and the money
we're gonna create and all the impacts
we're gonna have and the lives are gonna
change
it's fun it's this little brain teasers
a problem that we love working ourselves
through but nothing's gonna happen till
you start doing and what happens too
often is you come up with a plan and
then you start working the plan and then
you want to adjust the plan and then you
tweak the plan and you think about the
plan and strategize a plan and sit in
the couch and research and go to
seminars and watch more videos and
you're constantly tinkering instead of
actually doing where chances are that
first one you made if you just stuck to
it you'd be further ahead than where you
are right now because you would be in
execution mode in doing mode instead of
thinking in planning mode and I get that
execution is scary and I get that we
want to constantly adjust and make
things better but to member you are
stuck in line to perfection and that
creates procrastination and so you
always want to tinker and plan and mess
around with it instead of actually doing
so look at your calendar how much of the
things in your calendar actually lead to
you accomplishing your goals and then
don't look at your calendar again in
terms of planning strategizing for
another three months plan your calendar
say if I did these actions if I followed
what's in my calendar and I spent 95% of
my time actually doing the 5%
super-important it's thinking strategy
planning very very important but 95% of
time is doing look at what the doing is
in your calendar if you accomplish those
goals do your actions map to your
ambitions if yes then amazing then we're
not looking at our calendar for
adjustments for the next three months
and we're gonna be head down doing doing
doing doing doing doing doing doing
doing doing doing doing for as much as I
love strategy I love strategy I love
strategy games
I love strategy working with you guys
one on one when we do Instagram lives a
lot I love I love strategy strategy is
my thing I love it but as much as I love
strategy I do we make three videos a day
on the YouTube channel somebody asked me
was the last time you missed a video for
you to like one day we didn't post yeah
what was the last time you missed the
day like 'wow years like five years I
don't know you super sleuths can go back
and check it out
we don't even miss a series let alone an
entire day and so that consistency that
execution every single day is the
prince is the thing that will make you
great not just how great your strategy
is apply the 595 rule number two is
inoculate yourself against judgment one
of the big reasons why we love to plan
and think and tinker not actually do is
because it's scary to do because people
will judge us for doing because you're
gonna put up a video or make a product
or put your service out there and
there's a chance that people are going
to say no or laugh at you or reject you
or say that stupid or say you're not
capable and laugh you out of the room
that's that's a very real situation and
a lot of people will say well of course
that's not gonna happen you know you're
so great you're so talented and people
will want to listen to you know you know
like that will happen your worst case
scenario could happen you might get
laughed at you might be told that you're
stupid you might be told that this is
the worst idea of all time that is a
very realistic scenario and so I want to
prepare you for that scenario actually
happening but I think it's the best I
think when you can learn to inoculate
yourself against judgment I think when
you can learn to do your thing and do it
for the right reasons and and stop
caring about what other people think
about you that's when you ultimately
start to win I think people are not
afraid of failing but they're afraid of
failing in front of other people
you might sing in the shower by yourself
all day long if you're taking really
long showers but you won't sing in an
office karaoke party you won't sing on
the street corner you won't sing in
public because you're afraid of how
you're going to be judged and so I think
that most people play small by default I
think that you're constantly making
decisions myself included as a result of
other people's thinking and that keeps
us playing small and most of the time
you will not catch it but when you do
when you catch yourself playing small
when you catch yourself not doing
something because you're worried about
how it will be seen how you will be
judged what it's going to look like to
other people then you have to go and do
that thing I want you to train yourself
to inoculate yourself against judgment I
go so far off the deep end on this one
that I don't even care it's related to
my business when I took my team and my
dancing team out to get their nails done
they asked me if I wanted to do it and I
said no that's silly I don't I don't
want to get my nails done and because in
the back of my head I thought I can't
get my nails done because I have to make
videos and I have meetings and I'm doing
a presentation and that's ridiculous
because that was a reason that I had to
go I had because that was a little piece
of a reason that I had to go off and
paint my nails and I got them painted
orange with white racing stripes on them
it had nothing to do with my business
but I hate I hate I hate I hate making
decisions out of fear of other people's
opinions and if you can ever catch it if
you can ever catch it that that is
happening to you right now then I think
you have to go off and do that thing
even if it brings no business value to
you because it builds the muscle because
it gives you strength because if you're
off trying to do some big crazy
impossible thing you're off with a huge
mission you want to become a millionaire
you want to change the world whatever
your big ambitions are if you can't do
something as small as sing on a street
corner or paint your nails Orange then
there's no way you're gonna be able to
go off and do those bigger things either
and so anytime please please please try
to catch it
anytime you feel yourself playing small
because you're worried about how
anybody's gonna judge you your mom your
friends your co-workers the internet
trolls on online anybody you're worried
about their opinions of you then you
have to go and do that thing train your
muscle that you have to go off and do it
and inoculate yourself against judgement
and number three is be humble one of the
things I love about Will Smith is how
humble he is when he went from being a
Hollywood megastar and decided to start
a YouTube channel he started from zero
he start from scratch and now he might
have a good-sized following but it's his
humbleness
it's his willing to work hard that
allows him to win where other Hollywood
stars aren't I look at Will Smith and I
look at the rock as the two examples of
coming into the new medium where now
people Instagram and YouTube are bigger
celebrities and most mainstream movie
stars and so if the mainstream movie
stars are unwilling to start over to
start from scratch then they're gonna
lose and that's what most of them are
gonna do with Brad Pitt not going to
YouTube he is going to lose he is
already losing people are already
forgetting who Brad Pitt is but they
love Will Smith because it's willing to
be humble he's willing to eat dirt he's
willing to start over from scratch he's
not obsessed with how many views and
likes and hearts and comments and
subscribers he has he knows it as a
process is willing to work hard he's
obsessed about creating value and
building his base I look at what I'm
doing on Instagram as an example watch
what I'm doing on Instagram
I spent six years in Instagram barely
doing anything and building up you know
6,000 followers or whatever it was and
more recently been taking it seriously
and I'm in there I'm in there we're
posting six times a day I'm going live
four times a week we're posting the IG
TV like I'm in it I'm in it and I love I
love this starting over I love it I love
it so much and sometimes I secretly hope
this YouTube channel goes to zero just
so I can start over again I love the
process of building I love it when
somebody looks at my Instagram channel
and says that I have 29,000 followers
you suck compared to the 1.5 million I
have on YouTube I love that I love
eating that judgement when you could
train yourself to eat that judgement and
be humble and start over and be willing
to do everything building do anything
you need to get the thing done if I had
to sweep the floors and I would move my
business forward
I would sweep the floors whatever I have
to do to make my mission happen
I am super humble to go and make that
happen it's being obsessed about the why
like here's what I here's why I want to
create this thing but super flexible in
the house I will do anything I would do
anything within a moral code to
accomplish my goal and so being willing
to be humble being willing to have zero
results being willing to start over
being willing to be a student again is
so super important and it's really hard
when you've had a taste of success it's
really hard when you're Will Smith who
is the top of your game and then to
start all over
brand new on a new platform it's really
hard and it's one of the reasons why I
love Will Smith and it's a great lesson
you can learn from him be humble now
I've got a special bonus clip that I
think you're gonna really enjoy but
before that it's time for question of
the day I want to know what are you
obsessed about what are you obsessed
about what are you going to will into
existence even if you never get the
resources of the people the support
around you you are going to make happen
because you are obsessed about it let me
know leave it down the comments below
so how do you want to make money I don't
think this is what I do right take
yourself to five years where do you want
to be in five years
see the thing about it is to shoot a
movie you need a script right you can't
just freestyle it you can't say I want
to say this or kind of like that you got
to be very direct and then you put all
your energy to what you want you
visualize it and then it has to happen
I'm a filmmaker so I want to make movies
yeah I want to make I mean I've done
that but I want to do it to where I
don't have to worry about a regular job
yeah this is the way I would do it so I
would make as many short films as I can
just so people can start seeing that
you're good I would star in the movie if
I want to be anyone in this short film
like a real artist is someone that's
damn-near obsessed with it like a
painter should be painting eight hours a
day a band should be rehearsing eight
hours a day if you're a businessman you
should be doing your business eight
hours a day so if you're focused on
something and you're doing it eight
hours a day then you're doing it at a
professional level but you got to know
what you focused on and then you can
take things into your own control it
doesn't happen overnight it's not easy
expect pain expect anxiety expect
everything to go wrong and just be cool
breathe easy and then just see it out
because a lot of people start but don't
finish when things don't happen the way
it's never gonna happen the way you want
it to happen ever
and if it does do not trust it if the
devil look barrage it was something I
never dreamed I'd do
I never okay I only started thinking
about it four or five years ago when I'm
young and broke I'm growing up in
Louisiana middle class being told be
grateful you got a bite you be grateful
you got clothes on your back and you get
three meals be grateful for all that you
got cut you got it better than I do I
never dreamed to have my damn jet engine
whatever you have to do to keep your
purpose burning hot you do it you borrow
money okay use money if it requires
money so be it if you're truly obsessed
it will be worth it because you will get
the results you know the secret to
sustaining the
session is a straightforward one focus
your efforts on everything that will
fuel you for the long run and ignore
eliminate and block out anything that
drains you or causes you doubted money
power fame success all all of them
follow attention
so what gets the most attention is what
will grow the problem with these things
is money power Fame and success even
time off they require attention they're
like jealous lovers they need constant
attention or they're gonna leave you how
you invest your time is more important
than how you invest your money being
obsessed with your sense of purpose
across every part of your life
will allow you to accomplish all the
things you desire I think most people
are not accomplishing what they want in
one area life because they quit on all
the other ones if you quit allow the
other ones how you gonna get this one to
run nothing inspires me more than
surrounding myself with people who have
achieved more than I have and then
meeting new people
I need the obsess must surround
themselves with people you trust and
respect who think big you've done bigger
than you and who can help you get to
where you want to go you think you can
run only so fast time is no longer an
excuse because the obsess make time they
don't make excuses if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you up or so it would be
like a little beacon if you want more
Will Smith check out the best of Will
Smith motivation video that I did is
right there next to me I think you're
gonna enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there you say I'm gonna lay
this brick as perfectly as a brick can
be laid